let's talk about a very very bizarre
reversal involving Isis Isis has
reportedly banned women from wearing
burkas in northern Iraq and you might
say wait wait a second aren't they
enforcing the wearing of the burqa what
appears to have happened is that some of
their fighters were targeted by a veiled
female and they are they are now saying
no more burqa because we need to be able
to better protect our terrorists from a
woman who showed up and actually killed
two of our jihadists so now if you go
into the security centers near the Mosel
stronghold you can't wear the burka
anymore this is a group with so many
internalized contradictions that it is
absolutely beyond words at this point
their critics of the left but yet they
are trafficking in profits from fossil
fuel oil gasoline they are the ones who
want to enforce the burqa and the West
is not strictly and and solidly Islamic
enough yet now they are at risk of
having their jihadists killed by a woman
wearing a burqa so now it's no more
burka and northern Iraq to me this is
not it not doesn't really require a
specific analysis it's about the sort of
absurdity and total lack of any
consistency period in anything that the
Islamic state is doing and and as if we
needed more information or confirmation
of that this is it so what are they're
gonna be waiting at the the gate to the
mosque with bikinis handing out bikinis
or what's this what are they gonna do
it's so funny because first you see the
groups that defend the traditional
attire from many religions which makes
it very difficult to identify who many
people are and makes it much more
difficult to hide items on you and we
often say hey if you had to go through
TSA checkpoints wearing just underwear
it would be far more difficult to hide
anything and then all of a sudden now
because of security concerns the Islamic
state which is the group perpetrating
many of these acts says we really got to
strip down the women at least to begin
with only by removing the burkas because
we just want to make sure that they're
not carrying weapons yeah that's exactly
what we're saying and
and and you're the problem in many cases
but now you're having the same problem
we're having and you've come to the
exact same conclusion what this does
confirm to me is that the idea of going
through security wearing underwear which
I don't support actually but as a
thought experiment I think is
interesting might actually be really
effective because saying no burkas is
just one baby step in the direction of
less area that could be hidden I'm glad
to see terrorism has finally hit the
terrorists yes perfectly due justice
here